per me la prima volta e mi scuso già con
tutti perché sono molto emozionata ho
fatto tutti i respiri che mi hanno detto
posizione wonder woman ice abi dovuti
sono proprio
allora io nella vita sono un operatore
socio assistenziale uguale ausiliario
nell'azienda socio assistenziale
territoriale dagli spedali civili
devo stare molto attenta a quello che
riferiscono altrimenti lunedì sono
licenziata e sono qua per parlarvi dei
bambini invisibili
per chi non sapesse chi fossero sono i
bambini che vengono abbandonati al parto
la legge italiana dà la possibilità alle
mamme di poter partorire in anonimato e
di abbandonare il bambino in reparto
questo ha dato la possibilità di non
abbandonare questi queste piccole anime
nei cassonetti unici gli di alle strade
o peggio ancora sul tuo 20 centimetri di
terra anche se penso che molti vengono
ancora sotterrati
e proprio nel reparto in cui lavoro il
reparto di neonatologia del civile che
ho avuto modo di mettermi molto in
discussione scusa trapianti mettermi
in discussione e confrontarmi con il
vuoto che ruota intorno ai lettini di
questi bambini non vi siete mai posti la
domanda dove vanno questi bambini dopo
che vengono parte abbandonati al parto
nessuno lo sa non lo sapevo neanche io
nonostante fossi un ospedaliera da
tantissimi anni è stato nel momento in
cui sono andato a lavorare al nido che
ho scoperto che i bambini rimangono in
ospedale fino a che il tribunale che il
tutore del bambino è in questione decide
e trova la famiglia affidataria o
cattiva che potrebbe accogliere il
bambino nelle loro case i tempi
dell'attesa burocratici sono non lunghi
ma lunghissimi
se il bambino è sano può rimanere 20 30
giorni in ospedale
se invece il bambino ha dei problemi a
delle patologie rimane molto più tempo
il tempo può essere due mesi tre mesi
abbiamo avuto l'esperienza purtroppo di
essere vicino ai bambini che appunto per
problemi e persino mi gravi hanno
convissuto
scusate nella all'espressione con le
apparecchiature con le thermocool e con
un neon con rumori del del box per mesi
e mesi fino a quando finalmente
l'istituzione ha trovato una comunità
una casa famiglia per accoglierli perché
non una famiglia vi chiedete perché a
tutti piace avere un bambino sano perché
alla fine così anch'io se dovessi essere
in lista per un bambino per un'adozione
se devo scegliere ci hai un bambino sano
ma non sapete cosa vi perdete perché i
bambini d'arma sono veramente
meravigliosi
non c'è differenza tra un bambino sano e
un bambino con una patologia i bambini
dare ma hanno una sensibilità molto più
spiccata rispetto a qualsiasi altro
bambino ma anche rispetto ai miei figli
e rispetto a mia nipote perché hanno già
una sofferenza hanno già subito
l'abbandono già nel grembo
durante i nove mesi di gravidanza della
mamma dunque arrivano alla nascita già
con un karma molto pesante alle spalle e
questo questo male che rimane poi nel
loro inconscio li accompagnerà
sicuramente per tutta la vita e noi come
associazione d'arma
parlo di noi perché da sola non avrei
fatto niente
io sono stata come dicono tanti un
trattore che avuto le palle e ha cercato
di iniziare un percorso per star vicino
questi bambini perché l'ospedale non è
che faccia mancare qualcosa bambino
perché l'ospedale comunque da tutta
l'assistenza infermieristica e medica di
cui il bambino necessita che rimanga un
mese che rimanga 3 che rimanga 10 da
quello ma sul piatto della bilancia ci
sono cose molto più importanti
che l'assistenza infermieristica c'è la
kerr ragazzi chi è che non piace le
coccole cioè sicuramente qui ci saranno
tante mamme allora nel momento in cui
arriva un bimbo una mamma la prima cosa
che fa lo porta sul suo petto e li fa
sentire il battito del cuore
a questi bambini manca tutta questa fase
perché l'ospedale impegna i soldi per
tutta la parte assistenziale ma in caso
di tutto il resto non gliene frega sia
il bambino manca la kerr e se gli manca
la coccola se gli manca l'amore della
mamma non gliene frega perché non è una
cosa che gli compete all'ospedale deve
fare la loro parte e lì che mi sono
attivata e lì che mi sono messa molto in
discussione per questo impossibile che
nessuno riesca ad abbassarsi non mi
basta perché sulle calze quella che si
vedono però ad abbassarsi all'altezza
del lettino del bambino abbandonato e
capire il vuoto che ruota intorno a loro
a capire il bisogno di amore e io a modo
meno che non lo dirò mai come ha fatto
istituirla sono mi legano ho cercato di
iniziare un rapporto con l'istituzione
per acquisire la fiducia e essere vicino
questi bambini perché si chiamano
bambini invisibili giustamente perché i
bambini esposti vanno tutelati i guai se
non fosse così non sono bambini che
vanno i tic e tanti bambini che devono
essere vicino agli altri bambini perché
altrimenti tutti li vedono vengono
etichettati e si viene a sapere che un
bambino abbandonato ci dessero una
privacy
guai se non fosse così ma nulla toglie
che questo bambino abbia il diritto se
non di più
di essere amato che sia bianco che sia
nero che sia giallo verde come me come
quando mi alzo al mattino ma deve essere
amato e così ho fatto
mi sono rimboccata le maniche per modo
di dire poco in volto al tempo perché di
essere un po anche ruffiani e la
caposala della neonatologia del civile
che una mia grandissima amica e ancora
la mia caposala un'infermiera e abbiamo
istituito associazione in 3 nel 2011 e
abbiamo iniziato a fare le coccole ma in
modo serio perché si pensa che la
coccola sia accogliere il bambino tra le
braccia e dargli un bacio tenerlo
stringerlo la coccola deve essere fatta
anche con la testa deve essere fatta col
cuore ma bisogna anche capire che si sta
andando ad assistere bisogna anche
capire che non ci si deve coinvolgere
troppo quel bambino e abbiamo iniziato
con una buona formazione con dei
psicologi dell'età evolutiva con delle
puri pulitrici che ci hanno che hanno
donato il corso base con uno sportello
verde con una psicologa che ci appoggia
tuttora nel momento in cui siamo in
crisi e abbiamo iniziato a entrare in
punta di piedi nel reparto dico in punta
di piedi perché entrare in un reparto
dove c'è un equilibrio molto sottile e
molto difficile e come entrare e far
capire all infermiere alle prove
cultrici ma anche a me che sono lì che
vado a fare una cosa che loro non hanno
fatto fino al giorno prima ma non
l'hanno fatto perché non c'è tempo
perché
perché questi sono bambini in più dunque
tu devi spendere il tuo tempo con i
bambini che hanno le mamme loro vengono
dopo non ce ne sono di balle vengono
dopo
la pappa il cambio del pannolino è
regolare ma se c'è bisogno di una
coccola se piange viene preso in braccio
quando si ha tempo viene presenterà
magari quando si fa consegna e se hanno
i dieci minuti di tempo per fargli un po
di kerr sono bambini che vengono isolati
e messi lì nell'angolo
l'associazione cosa ha fatto è entrata
in punta di piedi e siamo andati a
compensare tutto l'affetto che una mamma
un papa dovrebbe dare al proprio bambino
lui abbiamo delle fasce orarie ben
stabilite non è che partiamo e facciamo
di testa non sta assolutamente abbiamo
un protocollo al quale ci dobbiamo
attenere
abbiamo delle fasce orarie con le quali
condividiamo con il servizio sociale che
ci dà l'incarico
sottoscriviamo i diritti e doveri si
paga se si sbaglia e si paga caro noi
qualche errore io personalmente col
cuore l'ho fatto l'ho pagato è però si
fa ancora perché non cedo e e si
iniziasse inizia a far la coccola quel
bambino madonna mia stesso avanti le
slide sono indietro io allora devo
essere più veloce
si inizia a coccolare il bambino si
inizia a raccontare quello che noi
facciamo col con lui durante la giornata
e lo facciamo su un diario che noi
abbiamo realizzato che sono il diario di
prigioni di vita e
su questo diario stiriamo tutte le
nostre emozioni
scriviamo quanto mangia il cambio del
pannolino sia fatto una cacca che
puzzava e sia lasciato i rifugi il tuo
zio felice perché così fra a casa quel
cimelio maglietta attaccata nell'armadio
perchè l'ha fatto solo con me perché
voleva bene solo con me a me e e questo
diario e è fondamentale per questo
bambino perché giorno per giorno noi
scriviamo la storia dei primi giorni di
vita perché come vi dicevo prima il
bambino può rimanere un mese ma poi
rimanera anche otto mesi lasciare nella
vita di un bambino un vuoto di otto mesi
continua farlo morire da grande vuol
dire che questo non vi verrò più avrà un
vuoto un malessere interno che che fa
paura perché comunque non sa cosa gli è
successo durante i primi otto mesi di
vita mettendo nero su bianco su questo
su questo diario noi diamo l'opportunità
questo bambino ma anche alla famiglia
che lo accoglierà di sapere che comunque
è nato si dà un grembo di una mamma che
comunque noi non giudichiamo perché
questa mamma ha dato la vita al proprio
bambino non l'ha messo nel cassonetto ha
fatto una scelta di vita probabilmente
perché non aveva alternative ragioniamo
così perché ci fa star bene a pensare
così è
ma per il bambino è importante perché il
diario è un tassello è il primo tassello
che gli servirà poi per costruire il
puzzle della sua verità
questo diario noi lo consegnamo insieme
una valigia il giorno che lui parte
perché
questi bambini quando quando partono noi
lo sappiamo 24 ore prima il servizio
sociale mi chiama e mi dice giovanni
domani paolo pietro luca quello che è
parte noi nel frattempo abbiamo
preparato il corredo ben bimbo ma che
corredo voi manco l'avete fatto i vostri
figli un corredo così ma né io per mia
nipote un fiocco bellissimo ricamato con
il nome la data della sua nascita
corredino fatto tutto a mano il cammi
chino e in questa valigia mettiamo oltre
che il diario tutti quegli oggetti che
hanno contribuito a risentire le sue
giornate nell'arco della sua
ospedalizzazione dunque mettiamo il suo
cd con la sua musica che ha ascoltato
per giorni e giorni
mettiamo i suoi primi odori il peluche
che li abbiamo che gli abbiamo comprato
e mettiamo il giochino mettiamo tutto e
quando parte in parte quel suo bagaglio
e per noi finisce nel senso che nel
momento in cui parte il nostro ruolo di
zio e zia e finisce dunque da parte
nostra ci sarà il ricordo di aver dato
l'amore da questo bambino ma nello
stesso tempo quando un bambino parte per
noi è una grande gioia perché ogni
bambino che seguiamo per noi una grande
crescita perché alla fine della coccolo
del coccolato come diciamo noi siamo noi
a portarsi a casa qualcosa alla sera
perché diventiamo sempre più ricchi
siamo siamo persone che abbiamo bisogno
di di ricevere amore perché nel ricevere
poiché si riesce
a donare e questo è il regalo più bello
che ci possono fare i bambini d'arma non
seguiamo solamente i bambini abbandonati
noi seguiamo anche i bambini maltrattati
triste quanto manca 21 secondi allora
vado allora i bambini maltrattati sono i
bambini che vengono allontanati
velocemente dai genitori sono bambini
veramente parlo sempre per la mia
esperienza massacrati fisicamente e
nell'anima bambini che vivono in questo
ospedale per per mesi e molti ritornano
nelle cliniche riabilitative perché
rimangono in coma vegetativo
oppure perché rimangono celebrolesi
trash che raggi mi raccomando i bambini
piccoli non si agitano in questo sistema
perché si va a far chiamare il cranio
non ci si rende neanche conto di quello
che si fa specialmente i bambini piccoli
perché si pensa che i bambini
maltrattati almeno 7 8 anni io faccio
parte di questa questa famiglia io
faccio parte del bambino disagiato
bambini disagiati e abbiamo anche a due
mesi a 3
noi seguiamo bambini da zero a dieci
anni e abbiamo anche assistito i ragazzi
fino ai 17 sud è veramente andare fuori
seguiamo anche
bambini e con gravi disagi sociali
siamo un aiuto concreto alle famiglie
che hanno bambini gravi in ospedali e
non riescono a sopperire alla presenza
ospedaliera dunque l'associazione d'arma
fa anche carico di 24 ore su 24 ma anche
per lunghi mesi nell'aiutare a queste
famiglie lo facciamo fisicamente e
materialmente il mio obiettivo è far
sapere a tutte le persone sono migliaia
le persone che ci hanno chiamato e ci
hanno mandato email che bisogna rompere
le balle agli ospedali bisogna far
aprire i reparti bisogna far sì che i
coordinatori dei reparti comunichino ai
servizi sociali che ci sono famiglie che
hanno bisogno di un sostegno le famiglie
se non sono sostenute in questi momenti
molto delicati si disintegrano alla fine
al posto di avere un figlio malato
oncologico il figlio si trova anche due
genitori separati finito associazione
d'arma